according to bf skinner if i can find
the appropriate punishment to motivate
missy there's no limit to what she might
be able to learn
but what might that punishment be
whip her with a rubber hose
no
that sounds like a recipe for tendonitis
administer small electric shocks
tricky if i get the voltage wrong i
could spend the rest of my life in an
institution for the criminally insane
or
i inflict harm on the object she loves
more than life itself
celeste you're about to become part of
scientific history
all right everybody welcome to the 1990
east texas baptist olympics
because we're in the pool of water
anyway i want to welcome our little
sister veronica duncan who i will be
dunking
sorry i can't turn it off
and i also want to welcome george cooper
who has recently found his way to the
lord
howdy praise jesus
are you ready to learn some advanced
calculus
nope
be right back
take your time
veronica do you trust in jesus christ as
your personal lord and savior
i do
it's upon your profession of faith that
i baptize you my sister in the name of
the father the son and the holy spirit
amen
wait in the water
[Music]
in the water
[Music]
all right let's try this again would you
be ready to learn some advanced calculus
if it saves celeste's pigtails what are
you doing
put her down not until i modify your
behavior
in the name of the father
son and the holy spirit amen
sheldon i'm warning you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
are you feeling motivated
very
[Music]
care to explain yourself i was trying to
motivate missy to expand her
intellectual horizons by torturing her
cabbage patch doll well it's not like i
shocked her with electrodes which was an
option enough to be clear i meant to
shock missy not the doll that would be
an effect enough and you getting
baptized just to kiss a girl what were
you thinking sounds like you know what i
was thinking
well you are both grounded
owl
i'm your number one fan i like you
because you're an alien but you're funny
unlike my brother who's an alien but
just a jerk
anyway i hope you're enjoying your time
here on our planet and have found things
to eat other than cats i recommend
chicken nuggets
sincerely missy cooper age ten p.s
my favorite color is pink what's yours
what a cutie pie hey hey barbara we got
any more of those pink t-shirts with my
face on them i want to send one to this
missy cooper kid oh oh and get me some
chicken nuggets huh
hello
anybody out there
apparently not
[Music]